Alright, now we're live.
Now we're live.
Okay, so...
Okay, first off, why am I the fuck am I...
Why am I Doki-E-E-Bird?
Alright, so the game plan is to try...
Get Evil Harvesters?
What if...
Evil Harvesters were fun, right?
I think so.
Yeah.
I see where the...
Seekers land, or maybe...
Do they land in one POI?
I feel like you should, right?
right they should land on one po i just so well actually
they stay in the ship until the very last second yeah so we
just have to land right away yeah jumping right away is
probably yeah oh cars are okay that is so fucking stupid
temple we need to get a car cars are allowed cars are
allowed yeah okay yeah you just play watson fun just put a
jet on a car wait you're all nrg should i be Okay, wait,
give me a second.
I'm going to change my name real quick.
Watson Octane car.
Oh, my God.
No, we have to get a car.
That's how, like, I won the last, the very first
hide-and-seek lobby.
We got, like, a car and we just drove around.
All right.
Let me give me a sec.
Let me change.
I'm just signed, by the way, guys.
I'm in NRG, guys.
How do I change?
Okay.
NRG.
NRG at DoC Bird.
Guys, I'm replacing their IGL.
They realized that a VTuber was just better publicity.
Is it Nocturnal VTuber?
I mean, he's more like a poser.
He's a fucking poser.
That's real.
When was last time he actually used his fucking VTuber shit?
He's just a flesh man now.
Yeah, he's a fucking flesh.
He's a fucking meatbag.
well not and not everybody's not even in the fucking lobby
yet also chat for those who are like wondering who's who the
whale is reptar for some reason and the cat is fun and
they're both used to be rank one pred so they're gonna carry
me right now for charity hi did seek tournament yeah in the
hi yeah in the hi did yeah in the hi does she turn it
they're gonna carry me in the hide and seek tournament thank
fucking god i don't have the aim anyway i got signed to nrg
guys real post this article in dextero right now okay does
anyone has anyone actually read the rules for this like like
what's our first is our first map world's edge i know we
play every map at olympus oh we play every fucking map oh my
god okay all right that's so fun so what is the god spot on
world's edge fun might as well just leak it now it depends
on the where the icicles oh where the icicles the icicles
okay but if you know the spot what of the other what do the
seekers know the spot well there's a isn't there there's a
zone yeah there's a zone it depends on where the zone goes
you can watch it go trials it's just gonna be 40 i be so sad
we just body block the tower trials fun i'm sitting inside
of one of the trial wait you can't do the trials never mind
wait wait temple's watching us wait temple they're like did
you say icicles guys i think temple no no no he's gonna he's
gonna use me and make rules no no no why is this guy always
watching why is this guy always watching why is he why is
the other pro players are just as scummy there's no way yeah
don't talk to me like that i just got signed
there you go oh hey at least like it's all for charity guys
it's all for charity we don't actually get paid we got free
like wi-fi modems are you guys using your wi-fi mode
are you guys using it okay i just wanted to be sure i just
want to what do you think we're posers yeah are you guys
posers are you guys using it you guys we got sent like a
care package that was like a it's like a fucking wi-fi modem
and it's just it has a apex legends icon on it to like
remind us that we're to remind us that it is a modem for
apex legends and then and then we got shirt and a controller
too let's see let me make sure all my settings and stuff are
correct all right nice the fuck said i'm trash oh okay it's
wake never mind for this if you want you what is the
controller gonna do aim assist your hiding spot like
controllers for driving that's true get that roller out for
the car way fun i could sit in crypto just give you full
info oh you're right and i can get every single uh evo i
love is that way yeah yeah we should yeah we should get i
just yeah but the thing is i'm not living longer than you
let's be honest that's true i might as well i might as well
support you yeah yeah we're just pouring all our support
onto fun we're just pouring our lives to blood to get fun
evo yeah yeah i see it wait what should i play then what
other character is good oh we should do like ring consoles
and all that shit too like oh we should yeah yeah you get
vantage so you can hit ball oh my god wait hit what you can
hit both i'll do advantage oh yeah okay i'll do advantage so
i can hit the the the other and then like we just get and
it's like you know where the zone's ending fun you know
where the zone's ending and where people are
yeah i gotta bring you guys both up on discord see okay fun
you're already at 200 for me What the fuck is wrong with
your mic, Fun?
I dropped my mix amp last night, and I think it might have
turned a bunch of stuff down.
Yeah.
You're literally at 200.
I have you at 200% too, I know.
Hello?
All right, Sound Guy, are they better now?
Well, I didn't really turn Fun up.
I just hope he did himself.
We're waiting for it.
I'm scared I'm going to be really loud.
Start without them.
Okay, no, that's toxic.
Okay.
It is but we're also eight minutes late.
Yeah, it's true.
Start without them.
I'll make up for their viewership
When they hear heard that I got signed they'll just be like
we gotta fucking go to her chat Yeah, you're still really
low fun.
Raise yourself up Oh shit, they're gonna start without them.
Fuck.
Yeah, just increase my gain.
Just all the way.
Yeah, just do it Fundraising themselves.
I gotta turn them down.
Just all the way up.
Yeah, what are you scared of?
Don't be a little bitch you're being loud that was like that
was like three years ago hello oh my god what the how did
you get lower like your voice lower oh his voice i was like
like how does voice get lower by more game oh my god it got
like so bassy wait wick actually believed i got signed
Like, I did get signed.
What do you mean?
You're gonna post my tweet in, like, 10 minutes.
Alright.
Yay, we're starting.
On Vantage, right?
This is, like...
Yeah, you put Vantage.
On Kings Canyon, I think...
I'm just gonna sit in map room the entire game What if the
fucking secrets go to map room?
I'm just gonna sit in the map room and I'm gonna spam the
button until I get murdered I don't know if that's my The
sound it'll get it'll get them all on one side of the map
It's so loud I'm just gonna be on the other side
All right sound guy let me know if their voices are better
now theme 14 who cares?
it I'll be on team 14 if they're that desperate then we'll
be missing one don't do that it's okay fun's gonna carry us
guys no phone would just be carrying me why am I putting my
sleeve on like I'm about to beam people I'm literally
running yeah just to just to like um get your running skills
higher I don't fucking know APM that sleeve on put it on my
keyboard the okay i raised up i raised up obs all right
let's go let's go let's fucking go
all right vantage where is vantage guys where's vantage
bottom left you got it okay nice wait should i be like oh
you're doing controller right wait should i be like your
character can do both oh i can do both yeah once we have
warmer you can do both with one of your bricks oh my god
okay i didn't know that this is how little i played vantage
wait reptiles i thought you're fucking oh you're oh i can do
both did i get tommy just keep healing in ring four i feel
like you're gonna die before actually setting that up well
you have the five you have the five minute cool let's go
climb it we're gonna climb it we're gonna climb it okay up
who cares we got two consoles all right where even are the
fucking so you can land on the beacon here yeah yeah on the
height and hit it yeah yeah let me just hit that real quick
and find all the people that's just i don't know i'm like
looking around for the evo harvesters that's one of the open
here i don't see any of them here you go don't worry getting
us that 300 right off the bat or 100 200 just so blasted
people with the Yeah!
They won't know it's us.
How would they know?
I think I see it.
Alright.
I need guys, I need blue armor.
I can't fucking press that thing.
Okay, we have a good, we have enough time.
They're still in the ship.
Where's the evo?
Spawn, damn it!
Spawn!
Where is it?
Come on, we gotta win this for charity!
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, we're gonna get that.
in 20 seconds crafty bat i'm gonna spread out i'm just gonna
go to skyhook all right i'm waiting for this ring console
i'm waiting for one of you guys wait he already killed
somebody guys he already killed someone that's fine they're
in they're in like mirage that's not my problem i'm alive so
waiting on my ring console i'm gonna grab the mence friendly
Friendly.
I'm good.
I got you juicy.
Oh, it's over there.
I got one.
All right.
Wait, yeah, somebody get that one.
Or I'll get it, actually.
No, no, no.
So I stay on the beacon.
Okay.
I got it.
Yay.
Okay, ring console.
I got it.
Here you guys go.
I hope that fucking grappler isn't.
All right, nice.
Oh, hey.
It's actually next to us.
Oh.
Yeah.
Is that a friendly or?
little overload i'm so scared when i look here one i know
right so i'm just like am i about to die what they're
playing maybe on pathfinder people on banghead i'm not gonna
like all i'm pathfinder bang and then well they might be
they might be octane to be honest i have no idea i know
timmy's on pathfinder that's all i know all right so like is
ghosting allowed open the stream open it up probably in your
chat you can tell you all i'm saying is that I somehow
figured it out but I I just look at you know just look at my
chat for like one second there's no rules against ghosting I
I would remember if there was all I'm saying chat is if just
tell me who they're playing we're gonna met a game what is
this I don't stand for this someone goes to Timmy's chat and
tell tell them where donkey is wait wait wait a minute i was
just joking guys i was literally i was joking i wasn't i
wasn't i wasn't wait what do you i'm literally your captain
all right guys i'm scanning it's a coup okay who's that
who's that i don't know uh wait the care pack the brick Oh,
that's big.
And steal the fucking Krabber.
Oh my god, look at everybody on our side.
If the Krabber responds, we need to throw it off the map.
Okay, two of the shooters are shooting right now, and I
didn't hear anything, so they're nowhere near us.
Okay, okay, that's good.
That's good.
And the other one's with the people, so nothing to worry
about.
All right.
Steal the PK, steal the PK.
What the fuck are you?
Oh, yeah, you steal the PK, come over here and throw it off
the ledge.
Throw it off the ledge here.
Okay, but what I will be sitting inside of the the under
your side overlook tunnel Dude, you want to sit we'll sit
the tunnel behind the fucking pills or some shit No, I'm
sitting on you know the height spot knock was on that the
other day or I was it you you would know that you were on me
Yeah, it was you There's no way they'll know I'm here,
right?
No!
I fell down There's no way oh wait, but here is this one
ring to rule them all?
No, come on Is this like in bounds?
we're gonna find out oh it's not guys if i get shot we'll
know why
it's a really obvious spot yo rep can you get on top of the
balloon no oh what if oh my gosh nobody will know i'm at the
dildo wait guys i think i'm dead wait what are you dead are
they there there's an octane right here stimming i don't
know if that's a person or not no it's okay all right nice
cool see nothing to worry about i just heard an octane
stimming down my hallway and i got scared wait can i do like
more than one ring right oh i can i can do climatizer ring
again all right i'm gonna i'm gonna leave you guys i don't
want to be near all of you guys you guys are gonna hit
double too yeah but what if they're there what if they're in
climate times yeah there's no way there's no way they
literally start off at the at the end of the circle
probability wise i would survive more over that side.
I'm very bad at math, but probability-wise, I think I'd
survive.
Also, we have purple.
I don't think we're getting red.
Might as well just chill.
Yeah, but we can get intel.
Friendly.
Do I have enough meds for this?
Yes, I do.
Okay, it's round one.
They're chilling.
Yeah, I have syringes.
Oh, it would be a smart idea to carry guns.
Just to be like, Hey, just to have all the friends run away.
No, no, no.
Just so they don't think it's you, you know?
There's a solo on a balloon.
Sounds solo on a balloon.
But they're all on the same team.
What do you mean they don't think it's you?
They do.
Yeah, they won't know.
They won't know, bro.
They'll just be like, you have a gun.
Oh, he's got a gun.
No, that's a friendly thing.
You see a gun in your back and they're going to run away
from you.
And then you're going to lead them to the actual seekers.
There's no rules against it.
It just says we can't shoot.
Just says we can't shoot guys.
Says we can't shoot people.
Yeah, and also NPCs.
And PvE.
Yeah, we can't shoot the NPC.
Okay, I'm scanning the ring for us, getting that intel.
Pulls away.
Guys, I might have- Oh, hey, you guys are in zone.
It's possibly the worst spot for hiding.
Where is my seek zone ever?
there's a friendlier near me too this is the worst oh my god
do you guys you guys don't hear shots right no okay so
they're not near us dude there's people in my tunnel that's
up where do i hide this guy's gonna get me caught hey show
your gun i don't have a should i just walk up to it with
just started shooting the scene i just got punched wait what
did i have to punch report them right now i just got punched
by an octane i said shooting at me dude this guy is like in
the my spot but worse is that luda is that luda or is that
actually like oh it's probably a real person or is it a is
that a hider oh yeah hider why is he shooting me wait
shooting you as in like actually shooting you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He was shooting through the hemmy.
Oh, he looted then.
Oh, okay.
Looted on Octane.
He's right.
Where is he?
Oh, he gots close to you guys.
That's him.
That's definitely him.
I'm out.
You guys gotta run.
I'm not moving.
Hide and seek.
Wait, somebody made a zip here.
That's scary.
Alright, if I run straight on, I'll, and I might be dead.
I don't know.
You're advantage.
You're fine.
Just remember your ability.
You want to have your bird in your pocket already and then
you hold it down, okay?
You don't like to re-throw it out.
Okay, hey, I have my, I didn't even realize the bird was
already out.
Whoops, I hope the scout.
Yeah, you gotta have the bird in the pocket and then you
gotta hold down the button.
It's, that's the rule.
The bird was already out, guys.
The bird was already out.
We'll put it back in the pocket.
All right.
Oh, there's another guy here with me.
I can grief them.
Oh my god, there's several people here with me.
I can grief all of them.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Wait, what?
That's okay.
It's okay.
Time seek.
This Valk is body blocking me into the corner.
What?
This enemy Valk is body, like they're holding me in a
corner.
I can't move.
I'm about to punch this bitch.
I don't even care.
Like, she literally has me body blocked in the corner.
Okay, look, they punched you once, so you have like one
freebie.
kid yeah one freebie oh he jumped i'm out quick this guy is
that a creeper it's a divo there's no way i'd rather have it
be a divo than a cabri i'm not gonna lie wait is there can i
be i got apple juice there's no way they'd see me over here
you're an octane stimming no you don't okay you're ready
don't don't hear anything i'll take my audio off you don't
if i don't hear it they don't hear like anything exactly
exactly there's no way they'll know i'm here i have like the
perfect hiding spot in the open oh guys we have to change
our skins after this game or fun does he's all colorful oh
yeah that's true eating hiding fun where's don't you know
about the skin meta no bro you're supposed to change it to
something white in the mountains no i well whoa whoa whoa i
didn't know it was the side of the map you know because it
was obvious come on i could have been i could have been i
could have been loving lava oriented you know oh well i hope
that was not any of those guys a scan beacon no no they're
not allowed oh they're not allowed oh thank god okay yeah
they're not allowed to scan beacon loot is right above me
i'm in tunnel wait how do you know do you hear shots oh he
just killed that grouch guy oh okay i'm gonna run then i
don't trust myself being here then no i'm not here you're
fine oh hey there's like other people here with me Fun is
near you, not me.
You're good.
I'm going to cross the map.
I'm going to go across the map.
Fuck this.
Hey, guys.
You're going into the zone.
Yeah, I'm going into the zone.
Fuck this.
Actually, no.
The zone hurts a little.
Who's that?
Oh, guys.
I'll see you on the other side.
You dead?
I'm going to go on the other side.
I'm going to go.
I'm going to travel across the map.
I'm going to travel across.
across the map.
I don't want to be on this side anymore.
This side's scary.
I'm even doing no traveling.
Oh, there's people over there.
There's people over there.
Oh, never mind.
I'm going to travel.
Just stop moving.
I can't!
I'm threading!
Find a corner and sit in it.
There's a dude sitting in this corner.
He's playing in-game fun.
Oh, no.
Oh, he's with you, fun!
He's with you!
Oh, Mirage!
Mirage!
Oh my god!
Wait, Mirage!
better because we're oh yeah they can shoot back there's
double aim assist there's double aim assist there's double
aim assist and it's not like you can shoot back like you'd
get away for two seconds and be like all right where's the
phone oh my god we should have had the gun in our backs we
should oh it's okay oh my god there's eight guys oh guys
leave me leave me guys okay he's where i am he's where i am
i'm excited to take away run we're run he's where i am wait
i'm resable guys no no no no that was the most crazy i'm
resable calm every res me res me now it's like no i don't
think so i can tunnel 100 like three 300 meters away sitting
in a corner i'm
I saw him That's fair Dude get away from me You see these
guys It was 100% Res of a I can't believe you guys won't Res
your IGF He knifed Greek He knifed Greek That's to me Oh my
god Bro you're so fucking dead The moment You had to rotate
No fun's not Yeah No you are though You're fucking dead No
I'm not I'm still alive How are you to do this how you're
gonna do this you wanna see yeah i'm watching i'm watching
how yeah make the loudest sound you can oh oh wait he has a
gun reptar he has a gun reptar he didn't hear or see
anything i saw nothing oh he's shooting in front of you i'm
sorry that guy doesn't know about the spot apparently is
that timmy was that no no no no that was uh luda that's luda
yeah let's see okay fun's also equally i see him fucking
running in the open right now with his glowing heirloom
knock's dead knock's dead oh we're better noob yeah can't
believe it that's why he's getting kicked off PENRG.
Sorry, we're even getting kicked off.
He's already kicked off.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, he's already, sorry.
They already announced it.
Yeah.
Right here live in this hide and seek tournament is when you
find out.
Okay, there's like gunshots, like literally right next to
you, Reptile.
I don't know about this.
Whoa.
It's okay.
That's okay.
Don't worry.
Is it okay?
It's all going to be okay.
Don't worry.
Yeah.
i feel so safe oh wait wait if you can like get behind him
i'm getting this guy killed i don't go yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm not letting him move he's not allowed to move i
haven't dropped in the corner oh that's an enemy that's an
enemy right there i have them both trapped in the corner out
of zone oh my god wait you do but you're no i don't you
don't i don't i don't i don't i don't i don't i lied why are
you doing duck hunt right now why did you do that because I
need to get away from those guys.
Bro, he's coming for you.
No, he's not.
All right.
What do you mean?
Why am I playing duck on?
I don't want to be next to them.
Yeah, but I thought you said you want to get them killed.
I tried.
What do you mean?
I literally tried trapping over the corner that I couldn't.
Guys, this is a rank one prank, guys.
Guys, this is the rank one.
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
I'm getting...
Find people.
Find people, Riftar!
I'm getting away from fun.
No, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I gotta find people.
That's a good job.
Find people!
If you're gonna die, you gotta take people with you.
No, it's okay.
They can't.
Yeah?
I found one.
Oh, oh, yes.
Dude, kill this guy.
Not me.
Kill him.
I found him.
Look, look, look.
bro all three feet away that guy didn't even get like he
didn't even die for that he didn't even shoot him that's the
worst part fun please you're our only hope you are as try
remember we put all our resources into you oh oh oh oh wait
that's friendly no no it's not friendly that's not friendly
fun fun fun i think he's fun you're Okay, he's going to get
distracted.
He's going to get distracted by that path.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see that.
Oh, my God.
What happened to the model?
The model fucking.
Oh, and I'm reasonable.
I'm reasonable, too.
Wait, we should play somebody to craft us.
Yeah, that would do a lot in this situation.
Yeah, not going to lie.
We could have got, we could have 100% been crafted.
Come on.
You can get top 10.
I believe in you.
Wait, that guy is, he's playing Lifeline with Sopras.
I think.
Oh, maybe not.
Wait, that's so smart.
Wait, what the, who's he?
T.
Drop him at his own phone.
That guy died right next to you.
He literally died right next to you.
Top 10.
We're top 10.
It doesn't matter.
Anyway, but we're still top 10.
We need top 3.
What do we do with top 3?
Top 3 is the only placement that matters.
We're going to charity even harder.
Okay, fun.
We saw that.
Dude, why did she come back?
I don't know.
That Pathfinder's evil.
It's okay.
Okay, we got top 10.
Why did he come back?
The path, dude.
What the fuck?
How did he not see this guy?
I should have gotten that Pathfinder killed.
I should have went for the Pathfinder.
Yeah, you should have.
What?
Oh, no.
How is he just sitting there?
How did he just letting him sit there?
How did Tempo live that long?
Was that Tempo and Path, bro?
What was that?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure the path died.
Oh my god, he did it!
That guy literally stood in between the rocks.
Yeah, he stood still for so long.
I can't believe it.
This is a scam.
I'm playing altar.
I got scammed.
This is where we got scammed.
We got scammed for charity.
That dude sold.
That dude sold my spot.
I shouldn't have moved if I didn't move.
True.
Yeah, he heard you.
He heard your fucking movement.
It's okay, guys.
We placed higher than Nocturnal's team.
Honestly, in life, that's all that matters.
Yeah, that's all that matters.
That's why I'm the better IGO.
Dude, they had 71 kills.
Holy shit.
All right.
Holy moly.
Hey, we got top 10.
Let's fucking go.
Who was it?
Where's Dolphin's team?
Oh, was he the guy that, like, riding you out?
Won't let me.
Won't let me view his skin.
Oh, is the lobby broken?
Wait, how is it broken?
The in-progress.
Can hiders pick up ammo?
No.
Why are we...
Oh, yes.
They're running out of ammo.
They're shooting us.
Yeah, fuck you guys.
You don't deserve ammo.
Zach Mazer, you're trying to kill my friends.
No, I won't help you.
Go craft your ammo.
If someone said I'm not a Fortnite lava.
Yeah, if you run out of ammo, just fucking punch.
We will take the Krayer.
All right, what map is in it next?
There's no.
One of them.
I don't know the order, actually.
Oh, I'm muted.
It is King's Canyon.
King's Canyon?
Oh, okay.
Same comp.
Oh, I'm going to alter.
Okay, okay.
I'll be vantage.
I'll start.
and everything.
Yay.
I bet you the people who aren't there just haven't didn't
wake up in time.
True.
What if we just play res comp and they run out of ammo?
That's so true.
Okay.
It was three strikes.
I'd be down.
Yeah.
I'll do it.
That's why Newcastle.
Like what's like they're going to run out of bullets, right?
Yeah, but that means we got to stick together.
Three people running in a pack is not hiding.
I mean like those Just one guy is chasing us.
We just keep resting.
Just keep dancing on the shield.
Wait, actually.
Just keep resting.
Actually.
Okay, what happens in Final Zone, though?
What about Final Zone?
We're still alive.
We wall off ourselves.
We swallow ourselves against the rock.
Oh, you're right.
We outnumber them by sheer willpower.
out.
All right.
We'll see.
We'll see how this goes.
No, we should do it for one game at least.
Do it when we get a car.
When we get- Oh my god, yes!
On Storm Point.
Storm Point, Storm Point.
Newcastle, Newcastle, Lifeline, and who's the third?
Did you just play Watson?
Just give us a J.
Can we give a Jinn on the car?
Yeah, give us a Jinn on the car.
No, I don't think so.
I think it only has the one spot on top.
Put it on the front and the...
Wait, can we not put it on the back?
I don't think so.
You're right.
You might be able to.
Wait, we could try.
We might as well.
The armored car strat.
If we're going to have a car, we have to play Lifeline,
though.
Wait, you might want to...
Wait, I might want to play Path for this map.
When King's Canyon...
She can zip over.
I'm playing Alter.
Yeah, I'm playing Vantage.
Don't worry.
We got this.
The heavy armored car strat.
armored car strap rampart walls on we just like gibby run we
just like gibby car we just like gibby car they can't kill
us no i'm not even kidding wait that's true wait what do we
do gibby newcastle lifeline i mean i'm we'll hide in the
open yeah hide in a car in the open they can't get us or
should we do like gibby newcastle watson or gibby newcastle
yeah well it's probably maybe we skip newcastle maybe just
do gibby lifeline Watson.
Oh, give me lifeline.
That red is going to be very tricky.
No, no, no, no.
It's not for the reds.
It's for the car.
We just live in a car forever.
The car is our reds.
Okay, give me lifeline.
Watson.
Nice.
Don't we got it, guys.
We perfected the strat.
Because the thing you have to think about, right?
The seekers aren't working together.
And if we're in a car, how are they going to kill us all out
of a car?
Oh, that's true.
That is so fucking true.
I feel like we should get another car just to distract the
main car yeah but then we don't have bubble on both cars
we're living because we have bubble no no no the lifeline
the lifeline gets away but then what the what's the point of
having a lifeline we can't rest all i'm saying is that we
could have one proof i feel like we couldn't like at first
we start off with two cars and then use the other car to
distract people and then after the zone starts getting
smaller we like we go we we we merge we merge our cars there
are no cars in kc i know we're planning yeah we're planning
yeah yeah we're 50 steps ahead of the seekers this game
we're gonna be tree gang yeah oh you're right you're right
to be shitty at trees wait that means like every all of them
will think that we're in trees but I'll be like in the open
because they'll know I'm not expected.
They'll be too busy looking up.
They just won't even look at the actual map.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They won't expect looking up.
I wish there was pruning in this game.
I would just prune.
They would never see me.
We should land somewhere with holds.
Brew.
Well, I thought you were going to be at map room.
You're going to let me know.
Brew.
What happened to the map room?
Wait, fun.
We can do the double hold.
Yeah.
Double evil on the hold and then hit map.
map room for insta blue oh true but you don't even need to
play advantage you can play play movement because we can hit
map room on this map shows us the world I hope map room is
not in zone so I'm I hope I hope map room was just out of
zone you got to start pointing your alt at people at high
other hiders for the seeker oh you're right oh it's first we
all just gotta land on map room
we just live there should i just open the holes with altar
you can't anymore it's patched no i'm pretty sure you can we
all live here i think i think it's patched i'm pretty sure
they fixed the crash but i think you can still go through
with all three guys i feel like it was we all live in map
room i feel like all the seekers are just gonna run mock 10
on to the map look yeah but they'll they'll see the map room
scans oh really if it ours first or am i just crazy
nice not a grenade fun wait does each scan give you armor no
not from this i don't think just just the first one oh okay
so i'm just gonna go i'm gonna go i think it does i have a
but actually no I'm gonna go do downstairs all right so
reptile is gonna live in the map room because it's not in
zone all right go all right I'm gonna go to this other scan
I think we get blue here oh we will assume it's the thing
spot yeah yeah you can just go to the beacon will be fun
yeah yeah I'll get it in the beacon Dude, this Gio Kinto guy
died for his last game too.
I don't think that guy knows how to hide.
I think he just lands wherever the secret is.
He's just like, oh, there's nobody going over here.
Let me go over here.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll know where the secrets are from this.
Why is everybody an air base?
What the fuck?
What's wrong with them?
The game ends, I guess.
Oh my god, an air base ending?
We need to go.
We need to go on the outside under the stairs.
Okay.
Don't worry, guys.
I've got the scan, too.
Don't worry.
Oh, do you want to go get the hold over here, South?
We got this.
All right, I'm going to head to Relic for more scans.
All right, if I die, don't come to Relic.
Good gums.
No, it's okay.
I think they're going to murder Air Base first.
Yeah, they have to.
Look, Zach's dead.
Bye, Zach.
I swear I have like the worst fucking alt Russ Because
that's a shooting all What if like I shot somebody's foot
Like is that like illegal?
It's not allowed You have a laser pointer I use as a laser
pointer Just pointed at other people I think Wait I'm so
smart Wait I gotta find someone to start pointing it at
people They're gonna be like stop dude Bro, okay, I don't
want to live long enough so I can use it as a laser pointer
and just point people out.
You have a grenade ripped?
Oh, I got one.
Grabbing, um...
Yeah, grab another one.
Alright guys, if I die in relic, don't come there.
Alright, heading over.
These are all my scopes.
And barrels.
All these attachments are mine.
I just hope... I hope the souls...
Wait, we can put it somewhere.
I think you do.
Or do I take the minus 10 second cooldown for IQ?
I think the infinite one, because it's so hard to see.
That's true.
Dude, we can go put it in Endgame and run away.
Endgame and run away, true.
Oh, like the deploy?
I don't know what that guy's doing.
I'm scared.
No, no, no.
My ult, have you played with Alter?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you got the CP ult.
All right.
I'm gonna go up I'm gonna go craft a I should only what my
crafting I mean I'm gonna go grab the bat yeah we'll craft
the bat just in case for cells oh they're scanning too all
right leave leave I want to scan as well all right you'll
see where people are here holy shit okay those are hunters
containment hunters
relic hunter guys I'm so reasonable guys don't don't head to
relic but like yeah
Timmy's there guys.
All I'm saying is that Timmy will leave Wait, you get my
banner and then you eat back home We'll see I swear that
would be the smartest thing you've ever done in your life
Where are you actually gonna do it?
You're fucking body more.
I'm not going to The fuck was that No, it's not Timmy.
What do you mean by that's the smartest thing I've ever done
of my life i swear to god it can't be him he has to have
moved on he moved on don't be a little bitch why am i
getting roasted by my dead teammate what is going on i'm
your igl
like i'm gonna plug you in and he's gonna kill you don't see
he's okay no res me okay we're gonna you're so fucked
timmy's gonna run at us bro i'll see you
later see you later this is such a bad idea I don't know why
you guys did this to me this has to be the worst idea we've
ever came up
With no, it's we the people.
Reptar, I'm so reasonable.
I'm going for round two.
All I'm saying, Reptar, is that he'll leave.
Okay, okay, no, Reptar, don't go for round two.
We might need you.
Fun's gonna die.
You're our only hope for charity.
No, Fun's alive.
Fun's alive.
He's fine.
I don't know about that.
Live is...
Wait, is that to me?
No, that's Luda, I think.
Timmy's on rev.
Yeah, yeah.
Got the movement.
Oh my god, that's my number rank one tread right there.
Bro, he's just chasing you.
Wait, are you actually getting me?
Wait, I think you can get fun after.
Fun's alive.
What do you mean?
I hit this man.
Oh.
I punched him on accident.
dude why are we playing rev and using havoc they're on rev
path because they're competing against each other yeah
because they they get to win more for charity yeah first
place seeker wins 10 grand yeah for charity right yeah i was
gonna say if they get 10 grand alone and like none of us win
any money that'd be so up how does tournament even work so
like the the the seeker that kills the most people basically
they get to uh choose like 10 pick a charity to donate 10
grand to of the choice um and the hiders team that wins the
most points behind the most gets to pick the charity we want
to donate to that's basically it chat i'm sorry fun i'm just
getting havoced i'm too far away from you to get your i
don't know if this is a smart decision so like let's hope
that for me and not you.
I'm just going to kill somebody.
I don't give a fuck.
For charity.
What are you going to do?
Deduct your money from charity?
Yeah, right.
That's a mirage.
You know a secret we never played mirage.
They can't take money away from charity.
It's fun.
No, but tempo can punish me, so whatever.
Guys, by the way, guys, have you heard about Nokia 8?
the Nokia Wi-Fi modem where you can play tournaments like
this over Wi-Fi Wow we're so fucked I love Wi-Fi I love
Wi-Fi to you guys we're all on Wi-Fi here all every single
one of us is on Wi-Fi you think I can do a ring scan oh I
don't like the sound of that.
That was me.
Oh, the hell is you?
I'm just letting you know we're over here.
Wait, what?
I definitely don't like the sound of that.
I fucked up my echo, but that's okay.
Wait I think I might die the zone, so that's not okay.
I don't know, you're fine.
It's only zone two.
You'll be good.
Oh.
You're okay.
It's odd.
Um.
what what what you can't just say um what is it is a is a
seeker dead wait what why the chat said luda died how did he
die how did he die i was all i was all tapped but apparently
he's in the kill feed oh he got shot did you shoot somebody
yeah i killed him with my pk that i had dropped i punched
timmy wait he fell oh my god he fucking fell how do you fall
there's like nowhere to fall oh there's definitely ways to
fall off the map what but like it's probably an air base
just fell off the map or some oh that's pretty stupid well
it's just timmy versus uh versus people What happens if all
the seekers fall?
Oh, that would be great.
What if I just carry this gun around?
Then everyone wins.
Alright, let's see.
Oh yeah, no, nobody's getting grenade off my body.
Yeah, do it.
Do it.
I don't think I can.
It does, it does, it does.
That spot you had it.
Alright, I'm heading over.
What if I do a scan?
Should I do a scan?
All right, they're gonna know I'm here guys.
They're gonna know I'm here Here you go.
All right, look, these are all the people Wait, did you
wait, it doesn't show for me?
Oh, it doesn't show?
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Now you know It's because I'm dead.
Yeah, I think so too Luda got altar kidnapped.
Wait, he got altar kidnapped.
That is actually too funny.
actually great wait that's actually fucking hilarious
anybody got a clip oh timmy's right beside me dude i i ran
into no name and timmy's just standing in the middle of the
fucking road like it's a goddamn wild west oh why is nexus
so far rector uh well i placed the nexus and then i opened a
pill on it and it broke out no oh this is a fun zone that
would have been my fucking like lifeline right there Okay, I
have Nexus and 18% again, don't worry.
Rep, you know the pipe on the second...
Outside?
Yeah, outside the window.
You could go up above the window.
That guy has an energized tip.
I don't like that.
That's not...
Energize is good.
I'm pretty sure the path is dead.
Because Timmy's on Rev.
Timmy's on me!
Don't come here!
But you know the spot I'm talking about?
like right here yeah and then you can go up and down freely
but there's also the other one as well as like the alco man
if only i had that beacon there it wasn't close enough to
you if only i had that beacon
go to the other one the other one's better i think because
there's a ledge
That's a friendly person.
No, it's not.
That's gunfire.
That is so friendly.
That's not friendly, people.
Bro, that was obviously Debbie.
What the fuck?
I thought it was a friendly person.
Wait, Peep's dead.
Finish her, finish her, finish her.
Wait, how did he die?
Wait, oh, I could have lived.
I'm sad enough.
How did he die?
He died to zone because he's a noob and he stimmed himself
to death.
Really?
Yeah.
You could have won that.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I think Timmy could die then.
He doesn't have the ammo for this.
Boom Razzle punched him too.
Timmy's just get bullied.
Well Timmy could literally just win the charity tournament
right now by farming all these people.
I think, I'm gonna be honest.
I think he's already won.
Yeah.
After this one, yeah.
Oh, bro.
We should be seekers.
Honestly, we die.
Honestly.
you should rotate you should get rotated out if you die to
zone okay guys we have to like if we we have to like kidnap
one of them off zone then like how the is timmy gonna have
enough ammo for this bro he baited he got baited into an
altar ult off the map wait do you have the clip yeah i got a
clip you need a clip of that I can't.
It wouldn't be a DM DM.
I want to see.
It's so good.
DM, DM, DM.
Share it.
He's actually staying over here.
Here you go, guys.
We're watching it live.
I'm watching it live with you guys.
Let's see.
What is this?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
What?
Wait.
Oh my god.
That is actually amazing.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy.
Bro.
All I'm saying is if you get if you get fucking baited off
the map, you should get rotated out.
You die to zone, you lose secret privileges.
You lose secret privileges.
Bro, all the hiders should just gank up on him and just
punch him out.
One, one seeker left.
Yeah.
When it gets to ring six, the hiders can fight back.
The hiders should all just punch him into the zone.
We're gonna do the zombies after round five.
They should just like all surround him.
No, because there's gonna be- He's just waiting.
He's just waiting.
There's gonna be more hiders.
So he should like, the seeker, the hiders should just like,
bodyguard.
block him out of his own just put four of them just living
right next to bro what am i watching kim is looking like me
what the fuck that was kim that was kim what there's another
raise he literally was just like holding his hand it's like
yo what's up yo what's up guy he's like what the do i do
wait did he run up ammo already i think he's just waiting
He's concerned.
He's like, Loba, put your ult down now.
Loba, put your ult down or I won't shoot.
Bro, I don't even think an ult's gonna help them.
I don't know.
Wait, that guy's just resting right next?
I don't think he has bullets.
He's trying so hard to find ammo.
The secret's hiding.
The thermite.
A thermite.
Oh my god, that's E-Rom.
Can I just start meleeing people?
Oh, an R-9?
Melee them?
Bro, oh, that's a waste of ammo, Timmy.
You shouldn't be wasting ammo like this.
Might as well do finishers.
You're losing ammo.
He's losing time right now.
He's losing time.
There's still 16 squads and 200 res beacons.
There's still 32 people alive.
You think I was really...
I mean, I could have lived in this book.
I drolled.
Who the fuck had a gun on them?
Okay, this is duck gun now.
He tried grappling.
Wait, that was a crazy jump.
He said, hello.
Hello.
Poor Timmy.
He was like, maybe he has ammo.
What are the odds?
Bro, he's over sensitive right now.
He's overwhelmed.
There's too many people going around.
You gotta finish the job, Timmy.
Where the fuck is you?
Wait,
you good?
Oh, that was a good shot.
It was Mandy.
Oh, my God, you're right.
I died three times, which meant like, I made him waste his
ammo three times on my body.
Yeah, true.
but I mean he should just give up at this point like there's
no he's not killing anybody else he's like thank you no but
why she took it down she took it down holy shit bro
g-dolphin is a g-dolphin g-dolphin is a g bro bro that was
g-dolphin Oh my god, it's personal.
That was amazing.
What are you seeing?
The grenade.
The singular grenade.
Secret grenade.
It's the old.
They're fucking pushing him out of zone.
They're the grenade in the air.
Oh god, they're all dead.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Oh.
Holy shit.
No way.
Wait, Timmy's gonna die early.
No, Timmy's gonna die early.
Jimmy died!
What is this?
Look at that, those bodies.
Okay, that was crazy.
It was fucking crazy.
Dude, you just whip out the wats at all.
Dude, I played caustic.
I played caustic.
Oh my god.
Play caustic and kill nobody.
You're not the one to do damage ability though.
No, no, as a seeker, you just don't even, you don't even
seek.
Yeah, you just wait until end.
zone.
That only works because two people died to zero, did they
ever fall off the map?
Holy shit, I can't believe that happened for the Seeker
team.
Glad we aren't doing Olympus.
At Seekers.
Rotate Seekers.
Embarrassing.
Bad macro.
Timmy's like looking for two.
I volunteer.
As the newly assigned NRG member, I'd never die to zone.
I can't be like, who did that?
Who baited Luda?
Who even bait?
Does anyone know who baited Luda there for that to happen?
Is that whoever that guy is he's a fucking king
Oh apparently was linkser Linkser did it.
It was a link.
Yeah, yeah, apparently it was linkser
Linkser you baited
DQ game for the kill so wait that was gonna kill oh probably
just from I don't even know how you'd get a kill on
accident.
How did Peep die?
Peep died his own.
He died his own.
He literally...
He stimmed himself down to one and then died his own.
Yeah.
I feel like that's like...
Dolphin had to leak troubling them.
I feel like that's almost as embarrassing as getting...
No, that's worse because he did it to himself.
He knew he had one HP.
Now we're on Storm Point.
Car strat, car strat, who's playing what?
Because we're doing the movement comp on the car.
Are we doing like, aren't we armoured car strat?
Should I just play Gibby?
Maybe we don't need everything.
Maybe we just need Gibby.
Gibby, Lifeline, Watson.
No, we need Doki Gibby.
Wait, why me Gibby?
I can't, I don't even know how.
That's a lot of responsibility.
Yeah, that's a lot of responsibility.
Bro, I don't even know how I'll put the bubble correctly.
No!
No cars!
No fun.
No cars, PVE?
No cars?
No cars, I'm mad.
We're just playing movement comp.
So what's that?
Path rev.
Or octane.
I'll do... Wait, what are you guys gonna do?
want to give them ammo but also alt excels alt excels yeah
picking up altics i mean you play loba i'll play path and
then we have the revtar all right okay i'll be loba then all
right and we're just grabbing alt excels yeah yeah alt
excels and bats and hopefully okay can't believe it we all
we had the armored car strat it was gonna be the strat yeah
tempo is just stream sniping He's kind of an asshole.
Yeah, he knew.
He fucking knew.
He heard us talking about us.
He heard we were about to have fun.
He was like, yeah, let's shut this down real quick.
Run bang.
Let's hotbox the end zone.
Ooh.
Nice.
The only reason there was actually an end zone that game is
because there's only one hider.
She tried to outplay the outplay the seekers, trap them in a
building.
Oh, true, true.
Put a loot stick in front of a door so they can't leave.
They could just kick the door down.
You jammed the door.
There's a bunch of rampart walls on it.
Wait, that's so smart.
We bait one of them into a room and then put like 200
rampart door.
So they can't get out.
Wait, what map are we playing after this?
Broken moon?
I guess so.
Yeah.
Oh god.
I can hide everywhere on that map.
I don't think anyone's gonna be dead.
Alright, here it is.
This is, this is it.
Yeah.
Don't worry, guys, it's okay guys.
No matter what placement we get, in the end it's all for
charity.
True.
For charity!
charity and wi-fi yeah for charity and wi-fi hey guys if you
what's the website again the apex wi-fi apex over wi-fi guys
apex over wi-fi okay uh i don't have the command because i'm
on youtube but if you go to reptiles and flower fun stream
which i assume they have the command right the exclamation
point apex over wi-fi you can join a giveaway um for free
stuff hashtag ad but we're not getting paid so it's not a
hashtag ad it's just we're just really passionate about
wi-fi in fact nrg is gonna play their world cup with wi-fi
uh yeah yeah as the igl i hope i hope that i hope that you
changed the router as the igl for nrg i will make sure that
they will play on
don't worry guys i'm here for you nokia sponsor me for real
no cars slash pve for hiders he said it four times and then
somebody said can we use cars no pve but why would most cars
win just collecting the cars down to sacrifice our points
just to have a car honestly same dq to get first
wait it might need to play octane wait but that means like
wait they said that hide seekers can use cars right yeah
they can't shoot while they're driving so we need to set up
road traps where they just get hit by octane pads on their
car i'm just thinking like what if like we just take the car
and then scare the other hiders
just be the roadblock of this journey just make it more fun
but get dekeed about it he's not I mean, we just scare one
guy.
My middle name is zone damage.
Who will die to spiders?
Oh, that's true.
Because there's no PvE.
They can hit us.
We can't hit them.
We can't hide in prowler areas.
You just run.
No, you can.
Because the prowlers will stop spawning.
Right?
Oh, yeah.
If there's more than one team, yeah.
Yeah.
All right, here we go.
I believe.
I believe in us.
Speaker Scott.
Speaker is intense.
Oh, yeah.
That's actually fucking crazy.
Camp the cannons and when they try to push you, just take
it.
If they take it, take it, take it.
We just need to play.
We need to collect a million bats so we can just bat every
time we take a cannon.
that's true or we put an altar portal down and teleport out
of the cannon oh my god that's so smart we just wait we wait
we wait at the cannon and how do we kill them how do we kill
them well we can teleport them off a cliff make a rave
portal at the cannon and the portal ends at the edge of the
cliff no make a portal and then the portal ends at an on an
altar all or an altar queue or something.
And then it's just like a little roadmap to the end of the
cliff.
It's just a domino effect.
Yeah, it's just a domino effect.
Just a portal, portal, portal, portal, death.
Rafe Ultra Ash.
Three portals.
That has to be like at least 100 meters.
Maybe 150.
Maybe more.
We can get 150 meters off.
of that rape altar ash oh man over 150 meters close to a
cliff oh yeah no they're absolutely not going to be entering
any fucking portal after last game there's no fucking way
they're too scared of them they're just afraid of dying
temple start the game start the game
tempo oh my god this had to see is wild what is this what is
it it's a it's a clip of how talking to nano oh yeah that
was what i was talking about yesterday about the anarchic
thing anarchic oh i can't I was like, are you friends with
fun?
Send a fun?
Yeah, I sent it.
Noba.
Wait, fun.
Do I just play Valk and just Valkalt away?
Maybe you can get it.
Well, you're Loba.
I'm just going to be able to get infinite ulti kills.
I can Valkalt away pop two ulti kills.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, my God.
It's over.
It's over for them.
Now I just have make sure i never press the q button i mean
you just be like it's an accident yeah but they be cute the
people asking for getting a kill so let's go oh wait we
don't have a beacon character oh wait a minute i think we
fucked up a little i'm in trouble good trouble i didn't get
on path no it's because you did damage yeah i know damage
seed all right I mean, there's no way go for the support
pill Yeah, I punched him.
I told them I told them you punched him out of fear He added
all of us why are y'all doing damage No, we're in trouble.
What do we do?
No, no, Tepo just added like ten people and was like why you
why you guys do a damage?
I was scared like fight or flight it was my life my life
yeah i mean if you were like getting red you would punch too
give me that bat my support character yeah you are yeah okay
so i'll be okay i'll be okay support so i got this guys i
know what i'm doing we need to go get the blue bins okay i'm
heading over don't worry now now i know what i am You
collect ammo.
Wait, someone fell out of bounds.
What already?
Yeah.
Guard that bin.
I think that one guy who keeps dying for us is just AFK.
Why is he AFK?
I guess like to fill up the slots.
Guard that bin for me.
I swear if some guy fucking comes in and going set.
That's our points.
Yeah, those are our points right there.
Okay.
Are we just splitting up this time?
Just collecting.
Collecting.
All right.
I'm going to go to Cascades to get more armor.
How far is your ult?
I'll probably come with you.
I have ult now.
Okay.
I'll just come with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll put it in Cascades and hope that no Seekers hears
the...
But, um...
Should I get the ultimate increase or...
I feel like I'm always going to die, so I'll just give you
guys my ult.
Oh.
All right.
Let's see.
I mean, would putting up fences considered a damaging
ability?
That does damage.
That is how that works.
No, but like, just don't, don't walk on it.
Yeah, my bad.
Just walk through it.
No, you're right.
Honestly, I never did.
Why did I think about that?
It's a damage by choice.
So like, if you just don't walk through it, you should be
fine.
Just don't take damage.
Yeah.
So it's cost of gas in that case.
Let's go north and grab the pill.
Yeah, I'm gonna grab that pill and then put down the ult.
Am I about to die?
Why?
Oh, friendly.
They spawn barometer, fun.
Okay.
Me and this wraith were both like shuffling back and forth.
Like, yeah, come in.
I'm putting it here.
I'm putting the ult here.
you're welcome let's hope that no seeker fucking runs in and
clocks us oh after this we should probably go i'm probably
gonna go down to senote i think they're gonna leave that
side of the map there's only one alt excel here okay okay
you should hurry and take it before these leechers take it
got it i'm gonna go on checkpoint i'll see you guys back
guys if if i die in checkpoint right on the run the opposite
side then you'll know we gotta keep our eyes I found friends
wait fun oh never mind I was gonna say advantage might be
broken but never mind I was gonna say because you can see
their their armors yeah but they know if they're a three man
so if you see a three man with armor you know it's the
secrets like red armor I mean true but then they're gonna
see your fucking sky no no no you can do the passive without
going through oh yeah yeah you just look at them yeah yeah
but you have to be on there we just have one person for
information and then we have Falk to get away.
You know, I feel like would it be easier just to be crypto
and then crypto can just like always have a drone out
somewhere?
Yeah, probably.
True.
Wait, we should do that for Broken Moon.
Just have a crypto put out the drone out and then like so
the seeker shoots the drone, then we'll know.
I'll play crypto and I'll just EMP everyone.
It's not damaging.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
1,000 damage.
EMP online.
No, wait, wait.
on the last round it won't count it doesn't matter because
it was it's the last game oh true what are they gonna do
kick me out of the tournament yeah the tournament's over all
right nice we got purple you're welcome all right i got the
evac too uh take an extra item reduce this tactical
All right.
I'm gonna go this way.
Where's fun?
Oh, wait, fun.
You guys, you're following us?
I was collecting.
I'm coming back now.
Follow us?
Yeah, we got purple.
We should split now.
I got a purple helmet.
There's no need for us to be together.
Yeah, we got- Am I dead?
What was that?
Friendly.
Is he friendly?
I think he's friendly.
Friendly friendly Okay Joki if you see an enemy in front
okay It runs straight to me okay We're gonna Valkylet away
Okay okay yeah yeah yeah But what if he shoots you And the
Valkylet gets cancelled The GG Yeah No just Valk just leave
me If I get shot just leave me And fly away No no no no
There's no way he's gonna shoot me He'll just be like I'm
gonna shoot the person I believe Wait Wait Wait no no that's
the ring Okay I was just saying The dragon dropped The
dragon dropped the loot at fox that's like wait a minute he
said wait i can't see over the ridge and i'm like uh do you
see somebody or not what's going on i forgot the ring can
make them drop the loot box i don't know maybe we can get
red there's a pathfinder behind you guys oh oh i think he
friendly i think he friendly oh i'm gonna keep running he
has a gun no i'm kidding i'm kidding he has a gun
Wait, I know there's, like, holes in the rocks.
Do you know where the holes in the rocks are, though?
There should be holes in the...
Okay, okay.
I don't know if both of us being together.
We're also out of zone.
Yeah, we're also out of zone.
Yeah.
All right.
We should split up, guys.
We should really split up.
I'm going to head this way.
He's climbing stuff.
We're good.
We're friendly.
Yeah, yeah.
They're all friendly.
Don't worry.
There's, like, a friendly guide to my left, too.
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go this way NRG is expanding now
guys.
I'm following you.
Wait, why are you following me?
Oh, I thought he had a gun.
He's just in the med kit.
Oh my god I thought it was fucking gone All I'm saying is
that there's no numbers.
He can't kill us all Yeah, it's wrong.
Come to me can when you meet He can't kill us all.
Did you watch that other end game?
Oh, that's true, but there was like 30 people and he was out
of ammo if he had a if he had a havoc i think all 30 of
those people would have been dead just didn't he have a
havoc yes he just if he had ammo sorry let me specify wait
wait do you think they're running energy yes of course okay
we should like grab as many energy as we can and throw them
off the cliff well if they're smart they're just gonna craft
it oh no no no look at this look at this it's like an easter
egg hunt yeah yeah it's like a little easter egg hunt give
you one more the hiders all i'm saying is if all the hiders
work together keepers over there wait how do you know okay i
just heard the flat line go off oh oh shit okay wait where
is he uh yellow ping somewhere i don't know i heard it east
okay i'm leaving yeah fun all i'm saying is if all the
hiders work together there's someone inside someone inside
and they're running around i'm scared they're running around
all right everyone find your own building friendly friendly
we all have a building they won't know are you friendly guys
leave us alone we're scared hello hello anyone in the
building oh friends only i hear so many people walking
around i don't know guys many people's good if it's many
people we're good they're not oh that's true that's true if
you hear one person running that's when you should be scared
what if it's one person then it's it might be a work and
murder so my child's like this is like the three little pigs
my house is made out of brick my house is made out of straw
we're both of the same type of houses it's gonna help and
puff and blow our house down
don't worry guys That's alright.
I'm in a really good spot.
Oh, I don't hear shots.
Oh, they kill Tempo.
Reptile, you see where I'm at?
Do you know where I'm at?
Are you inside, like, on top of the vent?
No.
Oh, where are you?
I just heard a rev jump.
Uh-oh.
I'm on, I'm on, like, the roof, but on the inside of it.
Oh.
If he gets murdered, Doki, run straight to me, okay?
We're gonna vote cold out.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can get murdered, right?
No they got rid of the spot up there.
No, no.
They heard the octane jump.
You're coming.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
What the fuck you're dying to ring?
How are you dying to ring?
They're scared.
Oh, because they're getting chased into a ring by peep.
oh there's a pathfinder on me and i hear him okay well it
can't be no it can't be people or luda so it has to be timmy
they're both shooting no timmy's shooting nobody's near us
nobody's we're good we're good we're also really far from
zone but we're good we're really far from zone but we're
good we're good we're just three balloons wait this guy just
hit beacon on me i'm following him all of them are hitting
beacon all of these guys are hitting beacon they're all
zipping to family family family family let's go family Wait,
there's so many Pathfinders here hitting the beacon.
Come on, Pathfinders, let's go.
If you die, we all die.
Let's fucking go.
Pathfinder strong together.
Oh my god, we're not a part of their kind, bud.
Yes, yes we are.
They're zipping for us.
Guys, I don't know anymore.
I'm fucking leaving you guys.
Ape strong.
No, stay together.
They're Ape strong together.
Ape strong together.
They'll shoot the Pathfinders, not the other guy.
Why does he have a gun?
This guy's got a point A longbow.
We'll try, wait.
He's using his to scope people out, fun.
It's actually smart.
I totally aged strong together.
I took a pad.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Now how do I get in a fucking tree?
Phone, look at me.
There's no way.
Come on.
Is this a bad tree?
I feel like this is a bad tree.
Is this a bad?
No.
Am I on something or no?
Am I just fucking cooked?
Is there people?
Wait, can I hide here?
Oh god, fun run!
Fun run!
See you later.
There's no way.
They won't look up here.
They're not gonna look at me either.
There's no way.
They won't look up, right?
There is no way.
Uh-oh, he's gonna look up to check the pack.
I feel so safe.
I don't.
I don't feel safe.
I'm not gonna lie.
adult guys i think i have an ingenious spot thoughts wait
does that guy have a gun no i think i think i blame you see
where i'm at you see where i'm at yeah you think it'll work
baby oh oh not over there oh timmy's next to me timmy's next
to me oh people's next to me too It's okay, they won't look
up.
They will not look up.
Guys, someone has to go on the other side.
They're literally all on our side, guys.
No, I'm not moving.
It's called hide-and-seek, not run-and-seek.
I think I'm good.
My spot is so good.
Okay.
Wait.
Doki, have you seen where we are?
No.
Look, I'm still in.
You still in up there?
I'm still in.
Wait.
I'm going to redeploy.
I'm running south.
I'm running straight south because they're pushing.
Run!
I'm gonna read a play.
There's no way.
There's no fucking- I'm gonna read a play.
Luna's on the southwest side of the zone.
I'm going to the southeast.
That guy is a Kramer.
I'm fucking dog holding.
I'm gonna read a play the last 30.
Oh!
Yes!
You have intel!
I'm out.
I'm out of out.
Oh my god.
The last 30 seconds I'm gonna read a play.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fucking do it.
here i don't know where to go there's no way there's no way
oh i'm so i'm so scared where are all the shots but i'm just
sitting i'm just sitting on the rocks the rocks are high
ground is your friend fun high ground is your friend you can
you can be evasive from high ground okay okay there's four
pathfinders up here fun i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
there's three pathfinders up here actually not for look at
us come here if i join the pack family family come here
dokey join the pack no i'm leaving this family what the our
numbers are going down they're dwindling oh stop moving get
kill us all um i'm just saying of them is definitely next to
me pathfinder strong oh valkyrie strong
well you need alt xels yeah let me get him up yeah yeah you
ready ready ready guys oh run run run run run run run he's
chasing me run run i have one near me don't come near me i
have one near me don't near me.
I have to go back up.
Go back up.
I have to I have to pad.
Oh, you gave them one.
Yeah, run.
I killed them.
Too scared to look.
Okay.
Oh, could you?
No.
I killed them.
Oh, God.
I shouldn't jump behind the pill with that guy.
I should have just jumped behind the pill.
I should have gotten us both killed.
But you gotta live.
You gotta live.
It's just us too.
For us.
No, you're not.
You're not.
It's Tibby on you.
Tibby and Luda.
Oh, God.
Run, Flores.
Oh, my God.
Run.
He's on controller.
They're on controller.
Uh-oh.
Is he a read-a-play?
No, there's no read-a-play.
Fun said, he has two of them on him.
No.
Okay, okay, now I know.
They're stealing each other's kills.
They're not even looking for people.
They're actually teaming up on you.
They're trying to get second, even though second doesn't
matter.
Wait, this is a deep hole.
What the fuck?
What is this spot?
I didn't even know this existed.
You're fine.
Don't panic.
He does not know.
He doesn't know.
I don't know about this spot, so I know Ludov.
does not know about this but he told you this what's this i
don't know i just walked in yeah go finish your narcturnal
that's narcturnal go finish her the horizon that is oh i
think so i'm like 99 sure yeah it was it was it was it was
yes it was it was it was it was it was That was worth it.
That was worth it.
That's why I'm the new IGL.
He's probably so bad.
He just got finished.
He's like, what the fuck is this lova?
Oh my god.
Back up more, back up.
You're behind the Pathfinder.
Why did you put a stamp?
You fucking whore!
It's okay, it's okay, you're top 10.
We're fine.
We didn't do damage, he was already dead.
It's not damage if he's dead.
Bro, we're so flunked.
I'm literally hiding behind somebody else's body.
Get ready to queue.
Oh god.
Wait, we the people.
Wait, we the...
Wait, no, no, no.
No, stop, stop, stop.
Stop, stop, stop!
That's a secret.
It's a secret.
That's like, why me?
There's literally a bad fighting.
You started punching him back.
I'm so confused.
I'm like,
I'm like, what is this doing?
There's no way you started punching it back.
I did not thought it was something I had to just punch me
around.
No, there's no way I did damage.
No, I did.
Holy fuck.
I thought...
I'm not saying it was either.
It was worth it.
Yeah, it was self-defense.
It was self-defense.
I don't think that's how that works in this tournament.
Oh my god, I need water.
I think this Octane wins.
This Octane wins.
Wait, no, there's someone behind him.
Wait, there is?
Yeah, he's healing behind him.
Wait, no, there's only two secures left.
One died his own.
There's just a low path.
Peep's died his own.
Again?
Yeah, he has it.
Yeah, I saw him.
No, no, no.
He got Riz.
Oh, he got Riz.
Oh, he should have kept him dead.
Because he got a kill after.
There's a lot of people just keep thinking though, David.
He's like one dick at a time.
Dude, they have no ammo.
They're just beating his ass.
They have ammo.
Bro, no!
Wait, you got second.
Oh!
That was funny.
Bro, has anyone had the reaction?
through our XIGOs.
It's a finish, Jake.
Very fun.
Pass the clip along.
Pass the clip.
Yeah, pass the clip.
He said, please tell me that's not who I think it is.
Oh, God, he knew immediately.
button past the clip button past the clip I sent it to you
it's too good I was watching it okay guys here's the clip
guys that gives me money
He's like, what do I mean?
I'm getting finishered right now.
I like how the POV is to somebody else.
So like, you're not even sharing with me.
Oh, Alicia.
Nice.
All right, what are we doing now?
What comp?
I don't know.
I'm going to play altar on broken moon.
I'm going to play pound.
It's time to run.
We'll play whatever you want.
And grapple under our bridge.
We'll be hiding under the bridge.
Alright, alright.
Are we doing the same thing?
Five teams tied for first?
Oh my god, that means they have to donate to five different
charities.
Them's the rules.
True.
That's the rules.
Those are the rules.
Charity rules.
If they don't do it, they hate charity.
It's true.
It's actually facts.
I didn't think about it that.
How could you hate charity?
I'm an asshole.
I know.
I can't believe it.
Tempo.
You can't just hate charity like that.
You got to donate to five different charities.
Oh, no.
Wig was reacting to it.
I wish Wig was watching our stream.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's see.
Should we still have ring character?
Oh, wait, no, you're on crypto.
Reptar, aren't you in crypto?
Oh, yeah, I can play crypto.
What were you going to play before?
I was going to play altar.
Ultra, wait, I can do crypto.
You can play crypto, go for it.
Yeah, I'll do crypto.
I'm going to play on my crypto.
You can hide in a little hole and just get on your gameboy
and fly around.
I'm bringing season four back.
Oh, the solo crypto is just fucking scanning people for army
and kill points.
you do do not dmp
wait you can just start driving your drone at rat oh you're
right i can drive my drone to like wait i kind of want to
play i kind of want to play crypto you can like you're gonna
rat other people out i'm gonna rat the people out 100 i know
you do you do crypto
there's so many buildings this map there's no way they find
me
this is this is this is where we get top three wait i need
to go watch peeps vod how did he die twice the zone i need
to hear his reaction oh that's true how did he die twice the
zone
there's no vod man peeps is embarrassed he deleted the vod
right after his first death you can do you have the
extension oh yeah the rewind yeah if you if you have it you
can it says like view and slash download stream without ads
what's the current blood damn i
just meant i is it is this the last game yeah it's a rad i
died to ube like three times in one screen block
wait he's just stuck in this room wait peeps yeah he got
stuck in Wait, how did he get stuck?
He killed people in a building in Zone 6 and he had no beds.
He just got stuck in the corner of the room.
I thought like he got stuck as in, there were so many bodies
just blocking.
Maybe we all, so we all jump out the ship and we all go to
like three different POIs.
We should do that, yeah.
We gotta do that.
I can hit ring consoles when I get blue.
I can...
Wait, am I doing Loba?
What should I do?
Wait, I'll do...
I'll do... Yeah, I'll do Loba.
I was just thinking maybe like...
Bangalore, because no one's playing assault characters.
Oh, you're right.
What if I bang-alted accidentally?
What do you mean by...
Depend on what you mean by accidentally?
For the last zone.
What if I had a calculated ALGS bangalore?
Yeah, what is...
It brings six.
And I'll be like, oops.
It's like, okay.
Wait, bro, how...
How peep died in the first game is even funnier.
He's just running around stimming you on the gas edge.
It just barely ticks.
That's his shoulder in the zone and dies.
Wait, you didn't click crypto.
You forgot crypto.
Oh, wait, you're right.
It's okay, I'll...
It's on me.
Thank you.
I was AFK.
I was watching the clip.
You can start grieving people, though.
It's my turn to grieve people.
Okay, now instead of...
This is up accidentally bang halting.
Wait, there's so many beacons.
There's so many beacons.
Can you land here, Doki?
Which way?
And hit all three of the beacons?
Oh, yeah.
Hell yeah.
I'm gonna go experimental labs.
Wait, can I do both ring?
No, no, no.
No, no, you can get in your drone and hit all of the man
scan ones.
Oh, okay.
From 200 meters.
So if you ping the thing and you're 200 meters out, you can
do that.
All right.
All right, let's see.
Oh, 100.
All right, here we go.
It's time to play on my stream deck.
How do I do this?
Okay, I have to hold the button down to get into the drone.
Time to put, go get into my steam deck right now.
Oh, there we go.
All right, let's see.
let's see where's the first one wait there's so many why are
there two here okay no it's too far wait no do not make it
no fuck you can just run forward yeah leave you a drone yeah
just don't worry my wi-fi is on five bars Got that good
connection?
I think so.
I hope so.
I ran out crypto Wi-Fi.
You see, if you get the Nokia modem, you'll never run out of
Wi-Fi.
This.
Ooh.
Wait, can I grab armor with the drone?
Bun, do you see anybody in the man scan?
No.
Why is it bugged?
that before i don't know i should be able to grab uh evo
casters wait my drone got destroyed oh no he punched it
that's just i was like because my drone was like right next
to the evo so i was like how the did he destroy it increased
neural link and emp range wait what's neural link you take
take the other one take the other one okay because that one
is like i don't the neural link is like when it shows how
many teams are in the area i think oh i don't actually know
well is that good for the for for seek for flying drone is
faster is better so they can't break that shit oh okay
because you're never imping anyways that's why that first
one is good but showing don't what do we want i'm in god
spot when we want them to to shoot it so we know where they
are oh but you want to be able to fly around them longer so
they have to shoot it and like be a Oh, you're so smart.
Yeah, we called her ammo.
That's why you're rank one, Fred.
You're so smart.
All right.
Let's see.
How far is this?
Okay, 280 to get closer.
Getting on my steam deck.
Okay.
What are you doing there, fun?
I'm gonna go to the beginning.
Collecting.
Oops.
More collecting.
Don't worry.
Hey.
I'm flying in.
Ooh!
Flying in.
I hope a seeker doesn't randomly shoot me because I'm just
in the middle of nowhere.
This Pathfinder just stole my brick.
I'm so sad.
Kill him.
Where are these people anyway?
Sorry to start killing him.
Let's see.
There's another scan here.
I fucking see.
Come on.
I was like, what the fuck is this guy?
Drone scan persists for 1.5 seconds.
Wait, we should want that.
Yeah.
Well, both are fine.
All right.
Going for the labs.
Let's get...
Oh, is that behind me?
I need a helmet.
I don't like the sounds behind me.
it's a pathfinder have a gun seekers are usually to sit
around edge i feel like yeah i mean that makes sense yeah
because do they know zone or no i mean no they don't have
their own character okay so i need to go whoever wait they
already raised they're probably doing it for evo i was gonna
say like what was this knock it looks like his fucking path
skin sit up here you know about the squat all right how many
squat wait lynx or fell was he trying to set up another
capture like was it him who did it the first time he has
voice lines off fuck fun you like my spot
oh i fly flight mode what is flight mode
Uh, I'm sure.
What the fuck is this pathfinder doing?
There's a pathfinder right...
If I put a drone right on top of this pathfinder...
You can't do anything about it.
Guys, look up here!
I went by a secret.
Wait, is that dog?
I don't know.
knock those are over here pathfinder over here oh wait oh he
kicked my drone he kicked it no that's what i did this man
destroyed my drone just just go follow knock around which
one he's on the low floor he's he's right okay yeah okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna throw my drone out i just hope i don't die
i'll let you know i'll let you know if anybody's running at
your building Okay, I'm waiting.
I'm waiting.
Almost repaired.
Bro, one of them fucking punched my drone.
Wait, two streams I'm not gonna go get a live reaction.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, you're taking damage?
Knock is punching fun.
That's fucked up.
Is he punching you?
Is that him?
Yeah.
No, there's this guy.
There's this guy right here.
This guy.
I'm going to scan him.
Do you see him?
I'm going to...
What do I just alt this, man?
That's fucked up.
Wait, am I... No, I'm not in zone.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
Look at him right here.
No, a zone ends here.
Oh, my God!
Oh, he quit!
I just want them to do that on his stream.
I don't have enough beds to do this.
Do you have beds?
I really have two shields.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Bro, kick this guy out!
Kick him out and never invite him to a tournament again.
Brood.
I'm going to EMP.
I'm going to fucking EMP.
Where is he?
Brood.
I have EMP.
Where the fuck is he?
Wait.
Where is he?
Where's that pathfinder?
He's above the zip line, above the rail.
The rail?
He's right here against this wall.
This wall?
This one?
The one I'm looking.
Find the building.
Is that him?
The pathfinder on the wall.
Yes, that's him.
Wait.
There's also this pathfinder right here.
Okay, let me just shoot a zip at it.
It's creeping so hot.
He's actually so mad.
He's actually so...
Bro, he left!
I got the sky!
I got the fucking left!
Holy shit!
Bro, he destroyed my fucking drone!
He keeps shooting my drone!
I'm gonna shoot a zipfinder.
at that that path there wait we need to make a web make a
web pathfinder have another have another drone coming in
don't worry you shouldn't take in the other perk no you
would have had your drone twice as fast no i didn't expect
it to get broken as much what is everybody shooting my drone
can we just get ulti cells and keep emping knock yeah let's
just keep emping like i have one we're gonna do kick us out
of a tournament it's over This is the last game.
Honestly, this is more content.
It's not an early game anyways.
Here, get out of your drone.
I got a present.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Ooh, nice.
Wait, there's a bunch of fucking loot here.
I'm taking it all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get all that loot.
I just shot a zip at him.
Okay.
I'm almost close.
I'm almost close to another...
This logo is just stealing all the ammo.
where is all the other chat i need a god rat spot oh that's
a wingman what the fuck this guy's a wingman wait i can emp
oh oh wait what's up wait i haven't dropped in the corner i
haven't dropped in the corner no he destroyed it he
destroyed Come up here, drop him in the corner.
Wait, no, I got a spot.
Okay.
No, a mantle!
No, a mantle.
Mantle.
Guys, we're in zone, we're safe.
We're so safe.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
I have EMP, I have EMP whenever.
I'm ready.
Oh my god.
Wait, what's the next ring?
Oh, ring, ring, ring!
Let me out!
Okay.
Steam Deck, let's go.
Don't EMP anybody but knock.
Where's where?
Where is everybody, though?
I'm going back up in my spot.
I'm going to stay here.
I'm going to find rat out people if I can.
Is there any rats?
There's just like nine people in your spot, right?
And Jimmy's over there.
They're all on me?
All right, I'm getting them all killed.
Leave me alone.
I'm handling my fucking my drone right now.
Wait, there's actually like six people up here There's two
people in this spot Oh my god, are there any rats here?
Where can I go?
Don't worry seekers.
I'll help you find out the rats.
Come scan my spot Doki.
How many people are up here actually?
Just a few Wait, I'm gonna bring a seeker over there.
I'm gonna bring a seeker.
Okay, no, that's...
Wait, I think that...
Wait, that...
This is one right here, I think.
Just playing gear troll?
Come over here, come over here, come over here.
No, no, no, seeker over here.
He's running grandpa for a mini gun.
Oh my god!
He is!
Come over here, come over here, come over here!
Come over here!
Bro!
I can...
You start driving at this.
You start driving at people.
Just driving at people.
yeah come over here come over here yes look up look up over
here over here over here over here come on come on rat fight
over here right over here right she's up front she's up
front oh yeah here i'll follow him don't worry don't worry i
got you
don't worry i got you he's ready on the roof come on red
part no no i gave you the perfect spot it was the perfect
spot all right don't you you're gonna get your building
cleared in a second just so you know if he clears my
building i'm gonna all you don't have bro now you're gonna
all by sheer will he's running into your building right now
oh no i'm giving you live pigs live pigs he's inside he's
inside don't look through no i was helping you i gave you a
warning i put on my way where would i run i gave you a 30
second warning and you decided to sit there and say if he
clears my building i'll emf you i was so close to my emf
though you don't understand it was so close go and get
banner hours oh yeah get the banner i'll res i'm just trying
to stay alive right now man there's a lot of people they got
weapons and but all i'm saying will be really funny if you
get my banner why don't we res you rector has a recipe kid
it's fine i got it don't worry yeah yeah wait you have a
mobile res i'm scared no wait did i get a recipe no no
there's a movie over here oh oh they're using it no no quick
there has be a moby somewhere i was gonna kick it out of
here someone has to have a moby oh nobody lose what do you
mean somebody has to have a moby somebody has to have a moby
oh my god oh brent sorry you're fucking policy for that what
do you mean but i got you uav bro thank you sir oh my god
bro you're Whoa!
Wait, unless...
Unless...
They've already cleared the spot.
They're not gonna look up here again.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
They don't... gamers don't look up.
Wait, why don't I...
Let me in.
Please, please, please, let me in.
Wait, we're...
Friendly, friendly, please, please, duh.
Let me in.
The door.
Kick the door.
Break the door.
You know you want to.
Come on.
Break the door.
and your building was stolen if he didn't clear that room
you were still good oh my god what is this violence where's
the path where's the other pathfinder it's okay fun i've got
the boys it's okay i've got the team i've got the phoepters
got us there's a moby you know you want to no don't don't
they're gonna to get to the movie don't do it i really want
to where are you he's literally in the rock i'm where you
that you set the zip line too fun i just oh well i just took
it to the to the other spot wait they actually got the res
off what the oh he's heading over he's heading over to you
oh no oh he's heading over
Timmy, don't look up.
Timmy, don't look up, Timmy.
He's looking up.
Stop looking up.
Oh, he's looking up.
Look down.
Timmy, don't.
You already won for charity.
Oh, nice.
I'm at 66%.
You should have used it all to excel for yourself.
Wait, do you have the increased fuel?
Yeah.
I can fly to the roof.
Do you just hit the fucking...
Hit the float?
The float?
All the way up?
Bro, they're just gonna duck hunt you.
What do you want?
I can't.
They can't.
for it they have other fish to fry oh my god everybody's
just wait there's another movie right there plug plug plug
the res oh bro the loudest fucking kill ever it's so it's so
quiet it's so quiet i'm in the air they're not hearing shit
oh safe so safe they're not gonna go up keep dying the ring
again peep there's no way there's no way i need to see did
he get res about this time i don't think they just gotta
leave him oh my god i just had a heart attack man if i was
still alive i could have drone so many people oh my god oh
my god the fucking rap part you look good bro bro that
shit's scary i think he's gonna clear a roof wait they're
resing no no no there's no way he's gonna go for the res
wait there's two mobis next to you are you are they using it
oh they are they might they might they might the bro you're
so we're dead you're dead there's no way there's no you're
so fucking way you died for that i'm not dead what are you
saying you stole that oh no oh no you mean i died for that
i'm not that run
wait you're alive what am i drone what am i drone don't my
god what am i just don't just throw it out just throw it out
just don't get it just throw it out okay maybe i won't it's
okay he's not gonna clear you i'm leaving you He's not gonna
clean me.
Wait, is there any more mobis?
If there's no one, you can plug us.
I don't think I'm gonna be flanking a mobi.
You guys go on Insta-Hitsit.
It Insta-Hitsit.
You're good.
Slowly.
Oh, you're good.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go.
Go all the way to the left.
You're good.
Just get on top of the ground.
No, no, no, no.
Chill, chill, chill.
You're fine.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Let's go.
They're killing everyone else.
No, no, no, don't flash your shield.
Don't flash your shield.
Don't do that.
No, no, no.
No, bro.
Enemy!
Delity... We got third.
We got third.
It's literally his teammate.
Oh my god.
I should have dommed.
I should have droned.
Reza's worth it, wasn't it?
I should have...
You were the survivor, not me.
Flew away.
SMH, teaming, teaming.
Teaming, teaming.
They're teaming.
Okay, this man Peep has got to get off on me.
What a fucking snitch.
Yeah, I believe they snitched us.
We got creeped.
It's okay.
We got third place in the end.
We got third place.
Jimmy had to res both them both again wait really all I'm
saying is they should have rotated seeker all right zone
what's your favorite charity who won charity who won the
charity tournament not us we don't know that we could have
clutched it out in the end That was fun though.
That was fun.
Yeah, that was really fun.
Stop that hard in a minute.
That was pretty fun.
You know what?
I had a great time with you guys.
That was fun.
Yeah.
That was a lot of fun.
I'm so early.
Yeah, that's like the only issue I have.
That it was so fucking early.
Dead.
That was so, so tired.
week funny and knock one wait did they actually win yeah
like overall yeah what the how oh they won the last game so
i only won the last one too yeah where's the points where's
the points yeah where's the point points the fun is over it
it's rigged it's rigged 253 points how dare they timmy
really says through loba i'm just gonna play rampart oh my
god that rampart all was scary as fuck he jumped in i don't
know how he got in behind me like that he like dropped off
the balcony is that the best part when it's a surprise for
you you know no comment all i'm saying is that like they
should deduct the seekers for points for dying to the ring
twice.
Like, at that point, they should have their points deducted.
GG's, guys.
I had a great time.
Oh, great time.
It was nice meeting you, Reptar.
It was really nice meeting you.
Thank you for the...
If you had any part of the invite, thank you for the invite.
Yeah.
It's great.
All right, I'm going to go peace out now and talk to my
chat.
GG's, guys.
All right.
GG's.
Good luck with your scrims.
All right, guys.
i'm gonna leave nrg yes oh you're leaving energy yeah guys
sorry i hate to break it i have to leave nrg because they
weren't paying me enough so i'm sorry damn it's really like
that i'm sorry guys i gotta leave i got an offer for another
team so i gotta leave you guys my teammates are always
getting poached man sorry guys i got poached guys so good
luck i hope you guys find a new igl in time to replace me
but i know freaking nocturnal guy again it's all good the
old one yeah i guess i know it won't be the same but like
you know maybe you know maybe you'll get far you know maybe
you all right cts cts have a good one bye bye bye hey guys
that was really fun that was i had a great time with uh
reptar and fun chat it was my first time playing with reptar
so uh fun invited reptar because like i i talked about this
before i was like desperate to find like substitute
teammates so literally i got fun and reptar in on like i
think on like monday or something like on the 27th because
we had like issues with finding like substitutes and like a
huge shout out to fun for uh for grabbing a third for me
because i was like i i cannot give up I'm just like, I'm
just like, I give up, guy.
I give up finding a third team.
You can do it, fun.
But it was a great time.
I wish we could use cars.
I feel like if we were able to use cars, it would have been
better.
I really wanted to do my armored car strat.
That would have been so good.
Hey, guys.
We still have a second stream for the member goons tonight.
So I'm just going to read.
super chats real quick uh and then we're gonna i'm gonna
take a nap and then get ready for the member stream uh
brolly thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you uh ima
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you jl is a nap
time 10 a.m is brutal am i right love you thank you thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah 10 a.m it
was a lot i'm not used to waking up before 12 chat i'm so
not i'm so not used to waking up before 12.
I did it I did it huge shout out again to Nokia for inviting
me to the tournament um and for sending a little care
package over uh and everything so yeah this was apparently
the very first esports uh tournament ran by ran on wi-fi it
still counts it's still an esports tournament because pro
players weren't in it pro players plus me uh so yes this was
apparently the first one uh on wi-fi um and they sent me a
free modem uh but yes thank you guys uh thank you to noki
again um as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around to get that blood flowing and you stay up
for me head to bed because you deserve it oh my god one
funny story before i leave um but like the day one for
wrestle tuber got flagged for adult content and i was like
what the fuck i was like i was like how like and then and
then like I told my YouTube guy.
I was like, hey, um, can we remove this flag?
Because they're like, we got a set.
We got age restrict your wrestle to provide.
And then they like, I messaged my YouTube guy and it got
instantly taken off.
Like the age restriction was instantly taken off the moment
I invest.
Because they're like, oh yeah, that's too crap.
Because I don't know.
I got age restricted.
I was like, why?
Why did he get age-restricted?
Anyway, I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.